дуже би хотілося щоб ця зала
прислухалася і зробила вигляд що не
байдуже тому що я нагадаю що коли 20
лютого 14-го року розпочалося московське
вторгнення
першими хто втримав Українську державу
першими Хто дав допомогу Українській
армії яка пішла на фронт гумових капцях
і без належної форми це саме були
українські Волонтери які на певний
період підмінили з собою державу І
допоки держава ставала на рівні ноги
обирала законну владу саме волонтери
давали можливість армії воювати Так ми
почали забезпечення із берців форми
шкарпеток Перепрошую трусів їжі але коли
держава почала міцніти 17-й 18-й 19-й
рік волонтери вже працювали про дуже
конкретних точкових проектах і мали
надію що навічно забули про Потреби
нульові Потреби армії На жаль 24 лютого
22-го року волонтери зустріли з тою
самою проблемою не було бронежилетів
казок форми берців тепловізори в
дальномірів і усього найнеобхіднішого і
хто став в основі держави знову ж таки
стали наші Волонтери які
поза всякими перешкодами поза власними
інтересами поза інтересами власних родин
робили усе можливе щоб армії забезпечити
сьогодні вони тягнуть машини коптери
техніку підсумки форму Берті знову яких
бракує бо за офіційними даними
забезпечення військовою номенклатурою за
ледве сягає
42%. і сьогодні почали переслідувати
волонтерів які з 14-го року чесно
активно і прозоро забезпечують армію це
не що інакше як дискредитація
волонтерського руху а отже послаблення
обороно достатності Української держави
я наголошую що правоохоронці які б
розпочали своє шествие антиволонтерське
із Закарпаття із руху підтримки
закарпатських військових і Галини
ярцевої Вони почали обшуки і слідство
без будь-яких взагалі на то наявних
документів зараз кошмарять порушують
процедури тільки на Львівщині 46
впровадження це означає що що всім
волонтерам припинити свою роботу бо
правоохоронцям Дана команда їх кошмарити
Я дуже Маю надію що Верховна Рада
зупинить цей беспредел бо без волонтерів
ми армію зараз не втримаємо тим чином
яким Вона має бути другий момент я
пропоную щоб перед тим як кошмарити
волонтерів відзвітувалися всі військові
адміністрації оскільки тільки тільки від
запитання про звіт у них починається
істерика і так не дамо образити
волонтерів волонтери і армія велика сила
Слава Україні